[Aplausos]
cómo
[Música]
sino seguir
si no se soltar
ah
[Música]
de cartón
d
[Música]
no no yo
y ahora
[Música]
nyse s
cómo
cuando hace falta pasar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no
para qué
[Música]
mi alma sabe
[Aplausos]
si no no
[Música]
mi cuenta de gas
si no lo es
y algo sabrá
[Música]
ah
esta ley
[Música]
[Aplausos]
está
[Música]
la
pero
[Música]
la reina
qué
na
hola
qué es
[Música]
y no sé
a
hola
quiero agradecer a hacer x por la
invitación
nosotros somos la máquina camaleón a los
que no nos conocen
bienvenidos
y a los que nos conocen ya saben
[Música]
i
puedo ver
hay algo entre los dos
[Música]
entre tú y yo
si te mueves me muevo me muero
puede ser magnética función
no sé si es amor
no es algo mejor
tú
[Música]
i
puede ser que pienses lo que yo
debe ser
si te mueves me muero de nuevo
puede ser
como a orbitar el sol
no sé si es amor no es algo mejor
[Música]
no
sí
que piense en lo que yo
[Música]
que muevas objetos
puede ser
cómo evitar el sol
pero mejor
de inicio
mis hermanas
un juicio
me dijo
[Música]
ahora
no lo sé
[Música]
i
por qué
cómo
él
[Música]
no no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias
es lindo tocar en teatros también por lo
general tocamos en bares sucios con
gente alocada gritando así que estoy
disfrutando esto gracias por estar aquí
alguien quiere pedir una canción
actualizas de primera
motora
esto es para ti
feliz puede subirnos guitarras de los
audífonos y para mi gente también
vinieron de colegios que colegios estaba
aquí
[Aplausos]
el mejor colegio marcoleta
[Música]
y
y mira
con ideas
y llegó
pero no
mi vida
ya está
no
mi corazón
m
él
llegará al mar hasta el fin de la tierra
donde el sol
[Música]
yo pienso
cara
de la tierra del sol
pero
entonces
según él
más
londres
con tiempo
sin duda
no te has estado
y yo quería
mi corazón manipular
no había asestado yo quería
en mi corazón
y yo no
me dije no pienso parar
[Música]
la tierra y el sol
el sol
[Música]
empresas
gracias
i
[Música]
y
vamos a cambiar algo bien porque esto es
nuevo y le vamos a probar diferente
entonces vamos a hacer esto
[Música]
mira
a la salida porque parece que no me
echaron
[Música]
viviendo
mira si estás buscando el frente como
límite olvídate del tiempo me vuelvo a
mí
si estás buscando
olvídate en el día
y bueno
como cristianos
el cielo limpio cambia
viví en la montaña
si vuelvo a vivir
y nos quedamos un rato
[Música]
alguien dijo la música
no nadie dijo así que de pésimo así
y es aquí se me vos grave
a la música
[Música]
por qué
cuando la música comienza a sonar me
vuelvo a encontrar en canciones que
hacen recordar
que todo descanso pero otra vez
comienzas a muerte mágico que él
y algo invisible tenga ese poder para
curar
[Música]
espero sabes que esta no es pero la
puedes jugar hoy es
y sabes que es verdad la música
nos va a salvar
a veces me olvido cuando la música
comienza a sonar nada malo puede pasar
es verdad
y todo está en su lugar otra vez
comienzas a moverte mágico qué es
es algo invisible tenga ese poder para
curar
y no
pero sabes que no
pero la puedes jugar oye
sabes que te dan la música
pero sabes
[Música]
hola
junto espinaca
[Música]
gracias
[Aplausos]